hello everyone in this video I will
discuss about in details the principles
of confocal microscopy and several
imaging parameters now if you watch my
previous video I hope you would
understand why we should use confocal
microscopy why it is a little bit better
than fluorescence microscopy what is the
basic principle behind it and in which
cases a confocal microscope could be
used in this video I would cover the
following topics I would cover why
confocal over fluorescence I would also
cover optical sectioning property and
see stacking adjusting gain and offset
and several other imaging parameters in
order to image optimally also scanning
modes used to scan the laser scan the
sample with the laser also detectors
used in confocal microscopy and what all
parameters determine the image quality
and resolution so stay tuned this is one
of my favourite microscopes this is a
Zeiss confocal microscope here you can
see the main part the main confocal 'ti
lies in this scan head so the scan it
holds a pinhole and the detector so this
is the important part if you get rid of
them then the rest of the microscope is
nothing just like a HEPA fluorescent
microscope and one of the reason to do
confocal microscopy is to get these
beautiful images but that's not actually
true here are two images two same images
which are taken in a epifluorescence
microscope and a confocal microscope
clearly you can tell in hepa fluorescent
microscope there are a lot of
backgrounds as if the image is like
fuzzy and blurry image also another
image you can see the same the confocal
image is way more sharp and crisp and
the resolution is better in case of the
confocal microscope image
and the reason being conformed uses
laser whereas epifluorescence uses
normal light of single wavelength so
since the laser has a property of
coherence the laser can be focused into
a very narrow point known as laser waist
whereas the waist is way bigger
in case of heavy fluorescence so the
chance that less amount of fluorophore
would be activated at a time in confocal
is high but in case of epifluorescence
quite a lot of fluorophores in the
surrounding regions would be also
activated and that give rise to that
blood now Clearasil here is a
fluorescence microscopy diagram so we
give a excitation light and let's say
our sample has Fitzie or gfp anything so
we are sort of exciting it with a 488
wavelength light and we're collecting
the emission in a camera so the
fluorophores
that we are targeting would be effect
would be kind of excited and we would
collect the emission light but the furo
force of upper and lower plane of that
image would be also excited and also it
would enter the camera that would result
in a blurry image whereas in a confocal
in the same excitation paradigm with a
laser we're collecting the emission line
and since there is a pinhole the pinhole
is income the pinhole is conferred with
the specimen plane that means the
specimen plane and the pinhole are in
same focus so only focused light can
pass so here is another light ray which
is coming from above or below plane of
that imaging plane so it cannot pass
through the pinhole and reach the
detector thereby we don't getting we are
not getting the stray lights and that's
why we are the quality of the image is
actually
increasing also the resolution now we
would talk about the optical sectioning
and sales taking property of the
confocal system so confocal system comes
with a motorized stage so the distance
between the objective lens and the stage
could be altered in real time and
thereby it can at a time image several
focal planes and after that all the
local focal planes could be marched to
reconstruct a 3d image of the object now
if I give you example it would be way
clearer so you can see here the the
objective is moving up and down or the
stage is moving up and down main point
is the distance between the objective
and the stage is changing and thereby
you're going through the image plane
York you're going all around the image
plane and imaging all the planes later a
3d reconstruction of the image could be
possible like this so we are actually
not physically sectioning whereas we are
at a time imaging from a particular
focal plane and we are collecting light
from a particular focal plane so that
give rise to these beautiful images
another important point and most
important point to get good confocal
images is to how to optimally adjust
gain and offset first of all what is
gain and what is offset so gain means so
gain is a simp simplistically gain is a
parameter change in which we can
increase or decrease the signal if we
increase the gain simply the signal will
increase later when why we would discuss
the detectors we would understand the
basis of increasing gain but gain mean
increasing game means increasing voltage
across the PMD
electrodes
offset means addition of a negative or
positive voltage now if I give you
example these things would be more
clearer now
here you can see this is the baseline
for the multiplier signal so even if
there is no specimen under a microscope
there is some amount of signal coming to
the detector due to some thermal
emission of electrons due to other
reason there are some kind of signal now
by giving a negative voltage you can
make that residual signal very close to
zero and then you can increase the gain
or increase the voltage across the PMT's
across the electrodes of the PMT you can
increase and boost the signal by
changing gain now here is a image where
you can see the gain here is increased
too much that means way too much voltage
is injected that's why you are seeing
everything is saturated so this kind of
paradigm is not proper another image you
can see here it is pretty much offset
but the gain is not increased properly
that's why still the features here that
we wanted to image are still dim so gain
and offset need to be properly adjusted
such that we get a proper dynamic range
of detection and in a moment I would
discuss what is dynamic range simply in
an image if we increase the gray gain it
would increase the signal but at the
same time you see the image looks more
grainy because the background signals
also increase while we increase the gain
now why does anyone need to adjust gain
or offset so in order to utilize the
full dynamic range of imaging a person
need to utilize a person need to
just the team and off set optimally here
you can see there is an image and this
image is quite proper an image that has
all sort of great values would be called
a good image so if you don't understand
this image I have another image for you
in this image the black black things or
black or blueish kind of pixels are
actually low valued pixels whereas a
yellowish pixel is very high value pixel
if you look at the image you would see
all Nisour all sort of colors are
present it's not that one color is
present more than other colors this kind
of all colors are blended properly so
all sort of gray levels are present that
means we have utilized the whole dynamic
range and we have kind of imaged for the
older values and captured all the
features of it now I would show you
three comparison here the image looks
too saturated because if you look at
these lookup table you can see there are
too much white into it that means the
image is too saturated in order to
improve the image quality in this case
you need to deduce gain or laser power
here the dynamic range is kind of proper
because all sort of gray values all sort
of range range of pixel intensities are
captured in this image whereas this
image has way too low signal because you
can barely see all the features inside
this image so we are missing a lot of
information from this image now I will
talk about another important feature
which also is important for a resolution
of thoughtful image is the digital
digital zoom apart from the normal zoom
apart from the normal magnification that
means for example we are increasing the
magnification from 40 X - 60 x apart
from that there is something called
digital magnification or digital zoom so
what happens in digital zoom let's say
the laser is scanning we are at 40 X and
the laser scan the hole
filled wholesale depicted here when we
increase the zoom then the laser would
scan for a small feature in the sill so
it's simply scanning the list area but
the image that would be produced in the
both the cases have the same size so
more so more feature would be kind of
displayed in case of when we increase
the zoom for example let's say there are
three pixels very close enough now if we
increase the number of pixels by
projecting the image into a bigger frame
then there are more gaps between it that
increases the resolution in other words
in case of increasing zoom we are not
changing the imaging size but a small
subset of feature is projected onto the
same number of pixels so pixels per
feature is more such that the image
quality gets better and also the
resolution get better for example here
is the image in 40 X now once we add a
3x digital zoom you can clearly see the
image quality has improved and the
resolution also looks way better now we
should talk about the scanning modes and
the type of scanner used in confocal
microscope so definitely we use laser
light sources for confocal microscopy so
laser kind of scans in a small portion
now question is how the laser raster's
in a sample in a small spot so the
answer is there are several kind of
scanners that are used in the confocal
microscope which are galvanometer based
scanner and resonance scanner why
different type of scanners are used
galvanometer based canners use 2 meter
which are perpendicular to each other
and they are vibrating well there is a
change in electrical field so Calvin
Ramirez scanners are slow scanners they
can scan at a rate of one to five frames
per second whereas the resonance scanner
are pretty fast scanner and they can
scan 30 frames per second so in order to
carriage fast dynamically life processes
a resonant scanner would be a better
option these days there is hybrid
scanner which employs both galvanometer
scanner and resonance scanner so those
are known as also hyper scanners or a
hybrid scanners next we would talk about
the detectors used in confocal system
con focus mainly used photomultiplier
tubes or PMT's now here is the basic
outline of a PMT so there is the
incident light incident light is the
emission light from the field of work
and it would hit a photo cathode now
this photo cathode is generally made by
multi alkali or sometimes alloy like
gallium arsenide phosphide now different
different material can be used to build
this photo cathode depending upon the
difference in the material infused the
photo cathode sensitivity could be also
changed however when the light hit the
photo cathode some electrons are ejected
that electrons are actually going
through successive anodes and ultimately
reaches the impaneled and there there is
another digital to analog to digital
converter which is converting these
signals and digitalizing this signal and
thereby the image is reconstructed point
by point now here is an example of two
different kind of detector that could be
used in case of multi alkali detector
the problem is when the electrons are
bouncing back and forth in the diode
arrangement cathode
the problem is there is a loss of
electron and that means some amount of
signal is also lost but in case of a
hybrid detector special arrangement of
the of the detector ensures that the the
kind of the loss of the electrons are
minimized so that's why hybrid detectors
are better now sure I would talk about
what determines or what factors
determine the image quality of a
confocal microscope simply the pixel
dwelling time laser intensity pin hole
diameter gain and offset floor for
quality and detector quality all these
factors are important in determining the
confocal image quality so I would
briefly go over to these points because
in the next video I would discuss these
points in details so pixel dwelling time
means how much the laser is dwelling on
a particular point so if the laser too
is too much time there is a possibility
of photo bleaching so you have to
optimize the dwelling time laser
intensity is another important factor if
the laser intensity is too low the
features won't be illuminated and if the
laser intensity is too high then the
features would be saturated and the
dynamic range won't be fulfilled in the
image the pinhole diameter is another
important thing if the pin hole diameter
is stool Neptuna or too less then what
happened a lot of signal would be cut
off and the image would be deep but if
the pinnacle diameter is more then what
would happen the out-of-focus light can
get through this pinhole
now also gain an offset or other
parameters that are important
determinant of image quality because I
have already shown you with examples
that if you properly if you don't add
just gain and offset properly the image
looks horrible and other than that
forever is the most important
if the staining or the fluorophore
quality is not good or exam the
fluorophore is pitched then you are
never going to get a good image in
confocal microscopy after that detector
quality is important now we have to
ensure that we are always imaging in a
linear range in a linear range of the
detector in order to get good images now
definitely the hybrid detectors or
kalium arsenide phosphide detectors are
way better than the multi alkali
detectors that's why choosing the proper
detector for your system is also very
important now if you liked my video give
it a quick thumbs up don't forget to
Like share and subscribe thank you